liverpool and manchester united are
among english premier league teams that
could join a new fifa backed
european super league tournament
straight to our city editor mark clyman
who has the details mark what can you
tell us
well sarah this is pretty seismic news
from the world of football what i
understand
uh this afternoon is that liverpool and
manchester united are among
a handful of english clubs who have been
approached to join
something that is being unofficially
called at the moment the european
premier league
now this new tournament is being put
together with a multi-billion pounds
financing package provided by one of the
world's largest banks
and i understand that it will include up
to 18
teams from across europe now the driving
force behind this project appears to be
florentino perez the real madrid uh
president
at least three clubs from spain would be
involved
up to five from england with arsenal
manchester city and chelsea
also likely to be in discussions about
joining the project and this would if it
does
materialize into a firm announcement
which i understand could come
in the next few weeks this would
constitute
probably the biggest shake-up in world
club football
for decades now none of the clubs that
have been approached have yet
formally signed legally binding
contracts
to join this european premier league and
one of the interesting things about it
is that it is as i understand it a
project which has
the endorsement of fifa the world
football
governing body now i also understand
that uefa
which of course organizes the champions
league and the other european
club tournaments is not directly
involved in this new project and if that
is the case
then it's likely to have serious
implications
for whether this new tournament can get
off the ground there are likely to be
legal challenges not least from from
leading clubs that are excluded from
this new
uh project my understanding sarah is
that
jp morgan the wall street bank has put
together
a loan package of worth about six
billion
dollars to finance the launch of the
european premier league now this would
be money that would be repayable from
future broadcast six billion dollars
being 4.6 billion pounds so it would be
one of the richest
team tournaments in the world of sport
as i say this could get announced in the
next couple of weeks but key
details are still to be finalized and
given the fraught
politics in football at the moment bear
in mind that just in the last couple of
weeks
in english football the political
landscape has fractured very
significantly
between the project big pitch over broad
project big picture
which was the initiative that was
proposed by liverpool and manchester
united
uh to reduce the number of teams in the
premier league
given this fracturing landscape there
has to be some doubt about whether this
new european premier league
will get off the ground but what we can
say for certain is that those talks are
underway
and they are at an advanced stage with
an announcement possible
as soon as the next few weeks